nicolas vidal bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
bonjour olivier bonjour alors quels
enseignements tirez-vous de cette
abstention historique nicolas et bien
voilà nous y sommes olivier la
déculottée électorale a fait rougir les
fesses vient de d'une autre caste
politique
près de 67 % d'abstention pour des
élections alors certes populaire en
soyons clairs mais qui reste l'une des
dernières aspirations démocratiques dans
notre pays chez olivier et comme je
l'avais prédit jeudi dernier dès potron
minet les français sont restés avachi
dans quoi élever dans les transats de
l'abstention fini les pêcheurs à la
ligne des années 90 voici les communards
lambda qui au lieu de brandir le drapeau
rouge ont fait un bras d'honneur depuis
leur canapé à la piétaille politique qui
ne cesse qui ne cesse de nier une
réalité absolument effrayante car très
sincèrement la situation démocratique en
france et très très inquiétante les
gilet jaune du canal historique l'avait
bruyamment exprimé vous savez est
annoncée fin 2018 et en 2019
mais vous savez aussi qu'ils n'ont pas
été entendus ni dans les manifestations
ni pendant le très risible grand débat
organisé à la va vite par l'elysée pour
faire finalement comme si et vous savez
où on finit les cahiers de doléances eh
bien ils ont fini dans les cages ebe des
archives départementales
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passait bien des français il présente la
facture
il exprimait un ras-le-bol massif et
alors ce matin nous allons essayer de
comprendre pourquoi cela ressemble de
plus en plus à une insurrection
populaire silencieuse qui pourrait avoir
des conséquences absolument désastreuse
olivier mais certains responsables
politiques attribue aussi cette
abstention convient de 19 et une
profonde méconnaissance également des
élections régionales et cantonales alors
est ce que vous partagez ces raisons
alors peut-être que ça soit jouée à
marges très sincèrement mais je ne crois
pas que ce soient les véritables causes
de cette abstention car ces deux raisons
servent surtout à se dédouaner de cette
gifle monumentale temps la classe
politique dans son ensemble a été
violemment discréditer néanmoins
néanmoins n'évacuons pas la question du
désintérêt des français pour les
régionales mais à qui la faute ollier
qui a redécoupé sur un coin de table
treize nouvelles régions 2014 dans une
loi territoriale enfin de caf 1 parlant
de créer de toutes pièces
de vastes territoires informel eh bien
eh bien c'est françois hollande qui a eu
cette brillante idée pour coller au
mieux au fédéralisme régional et
lointaine où nos voisins allemands
résultat on s'est retrouvé avec de
grands ectoplasme administratif avec à
leur tête des barons régionaux
alors je pose la question ce matin est
ce que la réalité territory d'un
habitant de saint jean de pied de porc
dans les pyrénées atlantiques et la même
par exemple qu'un citoyen de guéret dans
la creuse alors qu'ils cohabitent tous
les deux dans la très grande région de
la nouvelle à people
mais absolument aucune en réalité ou
encore est ce que les mêmes réalités qui
occupent un habitant de tarbes et un
habitant de nîmes même non plus alors
ces nouvelles régions n'ont aucune
matière organique et territoriales
communes
mais le problème est plus profond très
sincèrement et cette abstention est un
véritable acte politique je l'aurais pas
ce que c'est extrêmement important
c'est un refus délibéré d'aller voter
pourquoi m car ce pays n'est plus en
mesure de proposer une oeuvre politique
valable à une large majorité de citoyens
et ça et ça vraiment c'est gravissime
olivier nicolas comment est-ce que vous
jugez les déclarations d'une partie de
la classe politique sur cette abstention
alors on poudre on est ridicules voire
cynique temps j'ai l'impression
d'entendre les mêmes circonvolutions
depuis plus de 10 ans avec dès vous
savez olive il faut combat l'abstention
et se poser collectivement les bonnes
questions pour donner du sens à la
démocratie et bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla puis vous avez aussi
certains ténors et version trémolos chez
les républicains qui s'auto congratule
dans les médias et se réjouissent d'être
revenu dans le paysage politique prêt à
se lancer dans la présidentielle
omnubilés on l'a vu on continue à le
voir par la lutte d'égos inaudible en
train bertrand wauquiez et une pécresse
alors on va se dire franchement les
choses ce matin olivier quelle est la
force de la légitimité politique qu'en
plus de 33 millions de français refusent
d'aller voter et bien nada absolument
peanuts
pour le reste on a vu depuis dimanche
des chamailleries de cour d'école entre
les différents partis sur certains
plateaux télé dans le pti dans laquelle
l'un des présentateurs des moins
révolutionnaire du paf un le bien nommé
le nom subversif laurent delahousse a
fait part de son agacement sur le niveau
des débats il ya donné raison aux
attendes sioniste
mais rendez vous compte alors le niveau
le niveau d'indigence politique que nous
avons atteint en ligne alors quelle
serait pour vous les pistes pour
réconcilier les français avec le mode et
plus largement la démocratie alors je
vais me hasarder ce matin de modestes
conseils destinés aux esgourdes de notre
classe politique pour qu'ils évitent les
boulettes et nous épargne les palabres
premièrement arrêter de vendre français
le port franc républicain et le combat
contre le rassemblement national
ce n'est pas un programme c'est un
slogan des nuits qui a fait son temps et
qui sent vraiment le renfermé
aujourd'hui en moins ne connaît pas
programme sous la main dans ce cas-là ça
remplit le vide et ça couvre le silence
car la politique ce sont des projets cd
conviction et une vision pour la france
car faire seulement du contre ces deux
rien faire ou faire du bruit avec sa
bouche deuxième conseil je me permets
que la raim remballe immédiatement son
idée du vote par correspondance vous
allez parler d'un sujet précédent et par
internet qui frétille depuis quelques
jours avec un argumentaire désastreux
qui des grosses au mode en substance les
gens iront voter en masse s'ils peuvent
faire sache depuis chez eux mais qu'on
fait mais qu'ont fait les français pour
mériter ça je me le demande le vote
étant rituel républicain un dépassable
est pas une pluie de gemmes de smiley
sur facebook
troisième conseil ce serait bien
également gelé vue de faire remonter
rapidement et massivement le taux
d'occupation des sièges à l'assemblée de
nos chers députés
car ce que lorsque vous fouillez sur le
site de l'assemblée nationale et que
vous regardez la participation au
dernier scrutin public ça ressemble plus
de même à une atteint 906 assez massif
olivier puis dernière points il reste la
thérapie de choc
c'est du référendum populaire qui
pourrait faire revenir massivement les
français aux urnes encore encore
faudrait-il ne pas faire comme eric
dupond-moretti notre cher garde des
sceaux et sortir par la porte derrière
al annonce des résultats et coluche
disait un brin taquin mail entendu si
voter changer quelque chose il ya
longtemps que ce serait interdite alors
voilà pour l'actualité des régionales
avec vous nicolas une autre actualité
assez la suppression de 270 emplois
après la liquidation de la fonderie mbf
aluminium et les larmes de ses salariés
nicolas oui c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment effrayant ce qui s'est passé
chez ibm
malheureusement mbf pardon mais c'est
pas le sait pas le seul regarder
rappelez-vous olivier vous avez eu bosch
à rodez
vous avez eu bridgestone finalement à
béthune ya quelques temps donc on est
vraiment dans la casse sociale ait eu de
la casse sociale c'est pas la question
pour un cas social en dn2 scalise
finalement parce qu'on est dans les
ravages de la monde d'être
mondialisation donc on se retrouvera
exemple qui n'ont plus de travail c'est
au delà de la perte d'emploi c'est
vraiment de la perte d'emploi mais c'est
un problème d' art de vivre
c'est des territoires entiers qui vont
se retrouve avec des chômeurs et ça
c'est absolument scandaleux et vous
l'avez entendu depuis la crise du
coville bruno le maire notre cher mise
de l'économie qui lui disant qu'ils nous
disaient bien entendu nous allons
relocaliser mais nous n'aurons la
connaissons rien et notamment sur cette
histoire de mbf et c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que le gouvernement
avait demandé une étude au cabinet
roland berger qui avait dans un rapport
qui avait été commandé et qui avait
indiqué qu'il fallait se recentrer sur
deux champions nationaux notamment sur
les fonderie et qu'il fallait accepter
de ne pas pouvoir sauver tout le monde
chez olivier donc vous voyez bien
comment mener entre ce que dit bruno le
maire la main sur le coeur dans les
émissions et dans les grands médias
finalement il en passe temps de traître
mot il s'agit d'hommes pour bridgestone
à béthune qui a été délocalisée en
hongrie en pologne avec des fonds
européens
donc aujourd'hui en un le discours on a
le discours de la communication vous
savez on en parle tous les semaines et
vous avez appelé la réalité vous avez
leurs ravages de mondialisation vous
avez le carnage sociale parce que des
territoires comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
ces entreprises qui les faisait vivre et
on se retrouve en ce moment pour la des
industries qui te tente en train de
péricliter de péricliter et l'état
finalement laisse faire pour que tous
ces gens se délocalise et ça c'est
vraiment très très grave et ce qui se
passe à edf
ça va continuer je citais bridgestone je
citais bosch à rodez et ça va continuer
donc les grands discours ça suffit
il a alors vraiment un jour relocaliser
et se protéger également protéger nos
industries protéger nos emplois et
surtout olivier protéger notre art de
vivre parce que quand une entreprise
comme ça une industrie comme sa ferme
c'est tout un bassin d'emploi qui va
mourir et c'est dans ce contexte nicolas
qu'ursula von der leyen était à paris
pour donner son feu vert au plan de
relance
bien entendu hors schengen derrière
était hier à paris à l'elysée
ben c'est la maîtresse d'école cher
olivier qui vient finalement voir si
emmanuel macron a rempli toutes les
petites cases pour avoir le premier
chèque qui on est on l'attendait en juin
maintenant ça sera fin août ou début
septembre donc ursule abonnés elle a
fait le tour d'europe
vous savez c'est le club med le club
méditerranéen l'espagne la grèce
l'italie les pays du sud dont la france
d'ailleurs bruno le maire s'est inquiété
que la france ne tombe en seconde
division des pays est aujourd'hui
meilleur chemin derrière elle de faire
le tour des popotes pour savoir si
touché gens ont bien mis en place la
réforme la réforme des réformes
structurelles et notamment les réformes
écologique vous savez la réforme
écologie j'ai adoré ce matin en faisant
alors au plus près sa réforme écologie
de compétitivité ils ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher 16 ans de faire que la
compétitivité et vous voyez finalement
olivier le sujet en 3ème b entre
bridgestone et finalement bosch
c'est le même sujet au moment donné on
est sur cette idée là dans leur
rentabilité et de réformes structurelles
qui vraiment une casse sociale absolue
donc emmanuel macron il a reçu ursula
von der leyen pour dire qu'il avait bien
fait son travail et que tous les petites
cases été cochée voilà et qu'il recevra
chant chèque en septembre merci beaucoup
nicolas nicolas vidal qu'on peut
retrouver un sur les réseaux sociaux
en attendant de vous revoir pour votre
édito jeudi prochain dans la matinale